we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
question about who would I support if
Bernie fails in the Democratic primary
take a listen to this hi David
so right now
Bernie's kind of starting to drop in the
in the polls so I know you're big Bernie
supporter if you were to go down
who would you start to support would it
be Kamala Harris would it be Biden I
don't think it would be um let me know
your thoughts thank you yeah Robert
White listen it is I covered earlier in
the show that Bernie Sanders is no
longer in second place Elizabeth Warren
at least in the polling of the last week
has surpassed Bernie and Kamala Harris
and is now in second place so I first of
all I haven't endorsed Bernie I've said
the people I like the most are Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren I think
Andrew yang has some interesting ideas
although I disagree with the
implementation about many of them I'm
not a Biden guy I'm not a Kamala guy so
ultimately if by the time Massachusetts
votes Bernie is out
I would probably support Elizabeth
Warren on policy now I know a lot of
people say listen you you're supporting
someone who was a Republican for much of
her life on policy now she has most of
the right ideas she can go deep on
policy and though Bernie and Warren are
still the top two but I would not it's
too early to really be having this
conversation we've just got to let it
play out we haven't even had the second
debate which is coming up in a couple of
weeks so that would be my sense but if
in the end when it comes time for
Massachusetts to vote I vote in Boston
Warren is in and Bernie is out I'm
probably going for Elizabeth Warren
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about this new movement
the storm area 51 we will talk about New
Zealand starting their gun buyback
program and we will talk about the
Governor of Tennessee signing a
proclamation honoring some an early KKK
leader which has understandably sparked
a lot of backlash all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show